Salut à vous, qui aimez manier votre cerveau comme personne !
Aujourd’hui, on se fait un bon vieux Master Class' à l'ancienne,
un Master Class' des familles !
Le but de ce Master Class' est de pouvoir retenir un jeu de carte en entier.
Retenir un jeu de cartes en entier ?!
OK, c'est un truc qu'on a déjà fait…
J'ai tenté une traversée publicitaire.
On l'a déjà fait dans la vidéo numéro 79,
c'est-à-dire la 79-ième vidéo de l'année.
Mais vous m'avez beaucoup écrit, soit dans les commentaires,
soit par message en
passant par mon site internet,
pour me dire que c'était compliqué.
Mon premier réflexe a été de me dire
«oui, mais j'ai jamais dit que ce serait facile». Et mon deuxième réflexe a été de me dire :
«Mais j'ai une méthode plus simple, pour ça. En même temps, je pourrais leur apprendre.»
Alors je vous explique comment
dans ce nouveau Master Class'. Générique.
La première chose qu'il faut savoir, et
vous vous en doutez sûrement si
vous suivez cette chaîne, c'est qu'on va
passer par un système d'images.
Dans la vidéo 79, je vous proposais un système de PAO, «Personnage, Action, Objet», reliés à chaque cas
donc ça faisait cinquante-deux fois
trois images à retenir, plus les lieux à retenir.
Ça faisait beaucoup de choses à retenir.
J'en ai conscience.
156 images, c'est pas rien à retenir. En plus, il faut d'abord les créer au préalable.
Je peux comprendre que ça vous rebute.
Et puis il fallait dix-huit lieux mentaux pour les déposer.
Est-ce que ce serait pas plus
simple de le faire avec huit images,
que vous ne devez pas forcément
connaître par cœur,
et seulement neuf lieux ?
[Imitant les abonnées] Oui, oui, oui !
Tu m'étonnes !
Quand j'étais un peu plus jeune, j'avais un système pour faire ça.
Ça permet pas de retenir l'ordre des
cartes en entier, je vous le dis tout de suite,
ça permet de retenir les
séquences rouge et noir.
Et c'est déjà un bon départ, aussi bien vous pour faire travailler votre mémoire et
commencer à extraire toutes les
possibilités de cette dernière,
que pour bluffer les gens en faisant une petite
démonstration en fin de repas.
On va transformer les couleurs de cartes en
code binaire, c'est-à-dire que y'a que des
rouges et des noirs dans un jeu de cartes.
On va partir que sur ces deux choses-là.
Et bien en quelques secondes seulement,
vous êtes capable de retenir
si c'est «rouge, noir, rouge, rouge, noir, rouge, noir, rouge, noir, etc.» sur les 52.
C'est très bluffant, je vous le dis. Ça
paraît rien comme ça, mais c'est très
bluffant, quand quelqu'un mélange le jeu
de cartes,
vous le prenez, vous le passez en revue, vous le refermez, vous dites : «C'est bon, je sais.»
Encore plus rigolo, c'est si la personne le met de côté durant une heure, et au bout d'une heure
vous dit : «Alors, tiens, je le reprends et je te teste, maintenant.»
Et ben vous êtes encore capable de le faire.
C'est sympathique !
On va admettre que les cartes rouges valent « 0 », et que les cartes noires valent « 1 ».
Donc cœur et carreau : « 0 » ; pique et trèfle : « 1 ».
Et vous n'allez pas retenir 52 cartes, mais seulement 18 séquences.
Puisque vous allez retenir les séquences par trois. Donc à chaque fois que y'a trois
cartes qui passent, ça donne une séquence.
Si y'a trois rouges, puisque le rouge c'est «0»,
ça fait «000».
Si y'a «rouge, noir, rouge», ca fait «010».
Donc déjà, on vient de passer de
52 occurrences – on va appeler ça des occurrences.
52 occurrences à 18. C'est plutôt cool.
Avant de voir comment les stocker, ces
occurrences, on va voir comment les créer.
Y'a seulement huit combinaisons possibles, donc :
«rouge, rouge, rouge» ou «rouge, rouge, noir» ou
«noir, rouge, rouge»…
Et cætera,  je vais vous les faire en vous expliquant comment les combiner ensemble.
Pour créer mes images liées, et me demandez pas pourquoi j'ai fais ça, je me suis
intéressé que au «1»,
qui va me permettre de donner un nom, qui va être un petit code mnémotechnique que je vais
pouvoir enfoncer au fond de ma tête à l'aide d'une image.
Si on est sur la première possibilité, à savoir
trois cartes rouges, ça fait «000». Et
pour moi y'a zéro «1»,
à l'intérieur,
donc je retiens que le zéro, et avec le Z, je me fais mon image.
Quand j'étais plus jeune et que j'ai
utilisé cette possibilité-là pour
retenir des suites et des séquences
binaires, j'utilisais des personnages
que je connaissais très bien à l'époque.
Donc, je vous donne les miens, mais
vous en faites ce que vous voulez.
« Zéro », ça commence par Z, et donc je pense à Zorro.
Quand j'ai trois rouges qui se suivent, je
pense à Zorro. Ensuite, il y a « 001 ».
Y'a qu'un seul «1», et il est complètement à droite, donc je retiens que le D de « droite»
Ma mnémotechnie, c'est de me dire, le « 1 » est à droite, « droite ».
Et avec le D, j'ai choisi Donald.
Merveilleux ! Il y a également « 010 », et là, y'a qu'un seul « 1 »,
il est au milieu. Avec le M de
« milieu », j'ai choisi Milou.
Ah, moi, quand j'étais petit, j'avais des super-héros au top, hein, je peux te le dire.
Et encore, vous allez voir qu'avec le « 100 »,
comme y'a qu'un seul « 1 » et qu'il est à gauche,
je pense à « gauche ».
Avec le G de « gauche », j'avais choisi Gargamel.
Je regrette, maintenant. Oui, oui, je regrette, oui.
Cinquième possibilité, c'est « 101 ».
Moi, je pense à « encerclé », parce que le « 0 » qui est tout seul est encerclé par les « 1 ».
N'oubliez jamais que je suis focus uniquement
sur les « 1 », les cartes noires.
Et avec le E de « encerclé », j'ai pensé à Excalibur.
[Imitant les abonnés] Ah bon, pour la série Kaamelott, avec Alexandre Astier ?
Non, pour Merlin l'Enchanteur, de Disney.
Quand y'a trois cartes noires, ça fait « 111 ».
Pour moi, c'est la version
ultime des « 1 », et avec le U de « ultime »,
je pense à Hulk.
Oui, euh… Hulk, juste pour la prononciation,
pour le son, Hulk.
Je vous reprécise,
n'oubliez pas de créer vos propres
images, ce sera beaucoup mieux mais vous
pouvez garder ma méthode de « droite », « gauche »,
« ultime », « encerclé », … Ça fonctionne bien
parce que ça, on le retient quasi-instantanément.
La septième possibilité,
c'est avoir une carte noire, une carte noire, une carte rouge, soit « 110 ».
Et dans ce cas-là, vous avez remarqué qu'il y a deux
« 1 » qui sont à gauche. Alors moi, j'ai
créé un mot avec deux fois le G de
« gauche », c'est la Gorgone, alias Méduse
dans la mythologie, qui d'un simple regard
pouvait vous transformer en statue de sel.
Dans ma tête, c'est une espèce de bonne femme
avec des serpents à la place des cheveux.
Et le dernier, je pense qu'il vous plaira, c'est « 011 », donc une carte rouge, deux cartes noires
Et… c'est « droite, droite », donc c'est deux D.
Et les deux D pour moi, c'est Dédé.
J'espère que vous vous souvenez de lui,
c'est Dédé le cochon, des jeux
à gratter. Non, non, non, c'est
pas un placement de produit.
Vous voyez, c'est assez simple de créer une
mnémotechnie pour se souvenir de l'image
que vous avez construite, ou que vous
allez construire.
Vous pouvez très bien le faire
spontanément.
Avec le Z de « zéro », vous pouvez penser à un zèbre, par exemple.
Mais je vous conseille à chaque fois de garder
cette première lettre de ce procédé
mnémotechnique pour créer votre image.
Maintenant que vous savez les créer, quand vous allez faire défiler le jeu de cartes dans vos mains,
vous allez pas pouvoir à chaque fois retenir,
sans appuis…
Regardez, là, j'ai déjà passé neuf cartes, y'avait déjà trois séquences à retenir.
À savoir, un Gargamel et deux fois Hulk.
Il se passe des trucs dans nos têtes… y'a une ville.
Je vous explique comment vous allez faire. Vous avez
quasiment créer une nouvelle petite
table de rappel, comme ça, très rapide.
Et si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est une table de
rappel, vous pouvez quand même regarder
la 37-ième vidéo de cette année ainsi
que le 254-ième.
J'avais fais deux vidéos qui sont consacrées à ça.
Mais là, on va se servir de la 65-ième vidéo de cette année, à savoir
le palais mental simplifié, c'est
également appelé la méthode des lieux.
Cette vidéo-là, je vous la met en fiche ici, je vous la met également dans la
description, parce que c'est très
important, je vais pas vous refaire
toute l'explication, mais c'est ce que vous allez utiliser.
Assez simplement quand même, vous allez
pouvoir imaginez une pièce que vous
connaissez très bien
et dans cette pièce-là, définir neuf
lieux précis. Et mentalement, vous devez être absolument capable de vous
déplacer dans cette pièce,
sur ces neuf lieux, dans le bon sens,
dans le même sens à chaque fois.
C'est un petit truc à choper très rapide. Au préalable, avant de faire la
démonstration, hein. C'est quelque chose que vous
allez décider, là, maintenant, en regardant
cette vidéo, par exemple. Moi, ça pourrait
très bien être le bureau, où je décide que
j'arrive par la porte, donc la porte est mon premier lieu ;
ensuite, y'a ma guitare, la guitare c'est
le deuxième lieu ; et puis
je vais tourner comme ça, dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre, pour décider
à l'avance de neuf emplacements.
Une fois que ça, c'est fait, vous avez tous les outils.
C'est bon, c'est terminé. Quand vous aurez le jeu de cartes dans les mains, vous allez voir que
ça va être très rapide et très fluide. Peut-être pas les une ou deux premières fois,
le temps de se roder un peu à l'exercice, mais vous
vous placez dans votre petit palais mental,
juste celui-ci, qui sert au jeu de cartes, créer pour l'occasion.
Vous faites passer les trois premières cartes. Là, on sait que c'est «gauche», puisque c'est «100»,
donc c'est Gargamel. Ensuite, les trois prochaines.
Ça, c'est un Hulk : puisque y'a que des «1»,
c'est le «ultime».
Et moi, mon premier spot, dans l'exemple que je viens de vous dire, dans le bureau, c'est la porte.
Hé bien j'imagine, dans ma tête,
à la porte du bureau, Gargamel,
en premier c'est important, et Hulk, qui sont en train de combattre.
Mais vraiment de combattre. C'est-à-dire que, dans ma représentation, comme je lis de gauche à droite et que
je fais le tour dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre,
j'imagine d'abord Gargamel, il est à gauche, et c'est Hulk qui l'attaque de l'autre côté.
Ça prend qu'une seconde, à créer cette image-là
dans la tête, et elle
marquante, elle va me rester. Ensuite, je vais aller à mon deuxième spot, donc ça je le rabats
pour plus être perturbé. Je sais que là,
j'ai encore un Hulk, et là
j'ai encore un Hulk. J'ai encore deux Hulks d'affilée.
Donc j'avais dis que c'était à la guitare,
et bien je vais imaginer
deux Hulks en train de jouer avec ma guitare.
Un qui la gratte, et l'autre qui fait les notes.
Là ça me fait la Gorgone, c'est-à-dire «gauche, gauche», hein,
vous savez, j'ai «110». Et juste à côté, j'ai Zorro.
Donc à mon troisième emplacement mental,
je vais imaginer d'abord la Gorgone,
qui est donc sur la gauche, en train de
pétrifier Zorro comme une statue de sel.
Vous avez donc compris qu'en doublant les
images par spot, vous avez que neuf emplacements à retenir.
Alors, on pourrait aller un petit peu plus loin, et
on peut aller plus loin parce que c'est
quand même un Master Class', en se disant
que, si vous voulez, vous pouvez même
mentalement, avec un petit effort
supplémentaire,
savoir précisément quelle carte du
jeu est rouge ou noir. Si on vous dit la
40-ième carte du jeu, par exemple. Vous savez
que vous avez six images par spots, donc
six fois six, trente-six.
C'est ce qui se rapproche le plus de 40,
donc ça va être à votre septième spot
que va être l'image. Et 40 moins 36, il m'en reste 4.
Donc c'est pas ma première image,
mais c'est la deuxième image de ce spot,
et plus précisément
le premier code binaire de la séquence de trois qui représente cette image.
Ça parait peut-être pas simple, dit comme ça,
mais si ça  vous intéresse, repassez
lentement la séquence avec un papier et
un crayon, et ce sera beaucoup plus clair.
Si vous avez l'esprit un petit peu… comme ça.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
j'espère que ça vous aura plu.
N'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à laisser un bon, et gros,
et bon pouce en l'air.
Comme ça. Parce que c'est important.
Mais que si ça vous a plu.
N'hésitez pas également à m'en parler dans les
commentaires, d'une parce que je les lis,
déjà, ça c'est quand même important de
le préciser, et de deux parce que
parfois j'y réponds quand… quand je peux
et quand c'est des choses assez
essentielles, mais j'ai vu que vous répondiez
souvent entre vous, et ça c'est vraiment
cool, c'est un peu l'esprit du truc
Mentalo, tu vois.
Passez un excellent dimanche, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir. Vous pouvez cliquer
ici, au bas de la vidéo, mais ici aussi
également. Non, je me trompe,
c'est juste là, c'est ici que vous pouvez cliquer.
Ça marche également sur les
téléphones, c'est la petite nouveauté
YouTube du moment qu'ils avaient
commencé à mettre en place, et ayé c'est bon.
Et puis sinon, comme tous les jours avec le Mental Vlog,
rendez-vous demain, à 17 heures.
Bon dimanche, ciao.
(Générique de fin)